[Music]
so I brought some friends I'm here
joined by my colleague Sona who's a
solution architect in Google Cloud James
who's data scientist at creative agency
jellyfish and Tim who's CI a so chief
information security officer and global
need analytics and infrastructure at
Colgate big data is big business I put
up two very generic data statistics to
just prove out the size of the
opportunity but this is not new right
the reason I put these two dough is to
show how this opportunity is twofold if
you want to increase return on
investment you can do two things you can
create more return or you can lower the
investment so a lot of the things and
the applications that you see can be
worked and working both ways so either
you can untap new opportunities or you
can do the things you're already doing
in a more efficient way a lot of the
data that we talked about in the day
today is structured data
it's your advertising data it's your CRM
data it's your structured databases that
you can either access with with a sequel
query or a dashboard but today we talk
about unstructured data and what is
unstructured data unstructured data is
the type of data that doesn't come with
a predefined or an intuitive schema that
is easy understood by machines so
machines can display it like photos and
you can browse through it you can
interchange them but the machine will
have a hard time telling you what's in
the photo the same with we call an audio
video and an email for instance it's all
digital but it's hard for the machine to
actually understand what is in the email
so this is where the the big opportunity
is so if we know that half then 50% of
organization structure data is actively
used in decision-making this is a survey
this is probably on the high end even
because if you ask people that they look
at data before making decision a lot of
people gonna say yes but how many people
actually did it right that is that
number goes down to less than 1% if it's
about
unstructured data for instance you can
think of all the recordings of your of
your call center right those are usually
recorded for training and purposes and
what if you could actually tap into that
information right even in real time can
you pick up on on things people are
saying and trends that's the type of
data we will talk about today
this wouldn't be a Google Talk if we
wouldn't talk about AI machine learning
and in this case it really signifies
that bridge between your unstructured
data and your structured data so you
probably already have in place ways to
deal with your structured data but
machine learning really is the as the
bridge between between those data
sources and Google cloud then is really
the opportunity for you to leverage and
to use but Google has learned about data
in in the last last decade or so
developing their own algorithms and you
can apply this to your own data set so
what is machine learning well everything
is illustrated by cat in the dog deep
neural networks is a is a form of
machine learning and basically trains to
recognize certain patterns in
unstructured data in this case it's a
photo and it tries to figure out it's a
laundry basket is that a cat or is that
a dog so the animation on the right
signifies the different Network
different models that that the ML
application is trying to think about
what it is and if in the end it says
okay it's not a cat it's a dog it sounds
simple but what if you have to decide
whether this is a chihuahua or muffin
right this is really like if you're a
bollock and differentiate between these
two you're you're on the right way is it
the Labradoodle or is it fried chicken
sheepdog or mop right this really goes
to show how delegates some of the
differences are and how difficult it is
if you want to build something that you
can rely on in your decision making
right because sometimes 90% is not
enough why you need to be sure luckily
Google Cloud has a suite of products
that can address these concerns and we
will aware of the fact that ml and AI
the opportunities presented
different stages and different locations
in the company well you might have
actual machine learning scientists right
who write their own code who build their
own models we have the tensor flow
Network sorry the package it's a it's an
SDK that really allows you to to apply
the cutting-edge machine learning but
not everyone is equipped to do that
right there's a whole bunch of data
scientists that also might not want to
do it right they wonder on the one hand
build something specific to your
business and the other hand really use
the knowledge that Google already has
about images right if you think of
Google Images those are already all
digitalized by Google so there is ways
to leverage that in sites one way is out
of ml and it's basically a hybrid you
used a little bit of Google you use a
bit of your own and then in the left is
the app developers and those are the
api's those are really out of the box
simple solutions where you make an API
call you send a bit of text send an
image and Google will tell you what's in
it a sentiment score it goes pretty deep
and you will see into into use cases
what it actually looks like but what
does that all mean and what does what do
we care if we cannot make money out of
it right so how do you go from
unstructured data to business insights
so the last five minutes I've been
talking about the role that machine
learning place right so you have your
unstructured data you run it through
these epi eyes or do through your models
and that brings you to structure data so
Google cloud also has a great suite of
products that allows you to work with
that data right for instance you can
think of bigquery why that could be a
great destination for your structured
data and from there you can apply your
your standard more common analysis and
we start driving those business insights
I mean I work for Google so you probably
like well what else is you going to say
that's why we brought two customers on
stage who who will talk about how they
applied this type of logic in their in
their business and we'll start off with
jellyfish and I'll hand it over to my
colleague Jonah who will introduce the
use case thank you so much chef for that
introduction so hi everyone my name is
sona oakley i am a senior Solutions
Architect with Google Cloud focusing on
marketing analytics and machine learning
so today I'm going to partner with
jellyfish to talk a little bit about the
Google technology that we
used to help implement creative insights
and then the jellyfish team will talk
about the business value that that
unlocks for them so firstly when we
think about unstructured data every
single company in the world has an
advertising arm and a marketing arm and
we realize that we're sitting on a lot
of images that we could then use to help
generate these valuable business
insights so I'll start with a very basic
definition of what is it creative
because I understand we may not all have
a marketing background so creatives are
the visual materials that are used to
generate leads and sell advertising our
marketing we are all familiar with these
we're here today at next and I know I've
seen a bunch of Google Cloud creatives
as I've been walking through but I just
wanted to level set that this is what
we're talking about today and more
specifically we're talking about
creative analysis so that's the
comparison between two or more of these
images to determine changes in
performance so when we're thinking about
a marketing organization we think about
things like click-through rate
impressions clicks as metrics of
performance and we want to understand
how these two images compare and
contrast in performance as they're both
here showcasing the same the same
lip-balm so here we have the question do
lifestyle creatives perform better than
product creatives an example of a
product creative is this one here in the
middle where we're showing just the
product and a lifestyle example is the
one here on the right where we actually
have a model who's holding and
interacting with the product now as
humans this is really easy for us to
look at right we can look and we can see
then on the right there's a model on the
left there isn't therefore we very
easily classified this problem but two
chef's point earlier how can we have a
machine do this at scale and that's what
the power of Google machine learning can
really bring to the picture here is
it'll help us to be able to identify
these two the other question you might
be asking yourselves is why should we
focus on creatives there are so many
other aspects of an advertising or
marketing campaign like targeting like
recency like reach for example that
we've been hyper focused on as an
industry
however according to a recent Nielsen
study we saw that creatives still
contribute to about 45% of overall sales
so making sure that we have high
creative quality is imperative to our
business and it's almost a no-brainer
when we're running these ads to make
sure that the content of that creative
is of high quality and resonating with
our users and our customers so that
being said if it's a no-brainer and we
feel like everybody should be doing it
and 50% of the business relies on it why
aren't we right so the main challenges
that we face today are threefold it's
expensive it's manual and it's rigid so
it's expensive and manual because it
takes a lot of human effort if we think
about our two creatives that we saw
earlier today we would need humans to
actually go in and tag that though
creative on the right was a lifestyle
creative it had a model in it etc and so
that really limits us to only looking at
a subset of our creatives the other
thing is that it's a very rigid process
and that we have to think of of these
use cases ahead of time because we have
because it's so expensive and so manual
we want to make sure that we're getting
the most bang for our buck as we're
going through this analysis process so
with Google and jellyfish we thought
that there has to be a better way of of
doing this creative analysis piece and
we used Google cloud technology to help
do that so the first thing is that we
reduced costs using the vision API and
I'll go through each of these pieces in
detail but I just wanted to generally
introduce them so we reduced costs by
using the vision API which chef
introduced to do automatic creative
analysis then we helped to automate that
analysis by implementing a data pipeline
so that we were not just looking at one
creative we can look at multiple
creatives and then lastly we used App
Engine to allow for flexible scaling
here so now instead of just looking at a
set of a hundred we can scale up to a
thousand or multi thousands or even more
using the same process so that's how we
solved for this so the first thing that
we did was evaluating the cloud vision
API x' well it might be fun to upload
pictures of fried chicken and
labradoodles does this actually apply to
advertising creatives and does it have
any business value
for for our marketing organizations so
that was the first thing that we wanted
to try and hear if we look at the sample
creative we had uploaded this to the
vision API and we saw that it pulled out
three labels that we thought were really
important in doing this kind of analysis
the first is that it was able to
identify very accurately faces and
emotions so not only can we now see that
there's a model in those creatives but
we can actually see the emotions that
they're expressing whether it's joy
sorrow anger etc the next thing was that
we could do textual analysis so in the
bottom right where it says learn more it
was able to identify the text piece and
then lastly we were able to identify the
dominant colors so this helps to ensure
the quality of the creative by ensuring
that our creatives are on brand and
using the color scheme that's that's
been recommended so that first part was
a success and we were able to prove that
it worked for one creative but I don't
know you guys for me I don't really
appreciate you know uploading one
creative at a time and downloading them
so to that end we went ahead and created
a data pipeline that took our creatives
out of campaign manager which is a
Google marketing platform product that
houses all of an advertiser's campaign
information and creative information in
one place so this was the data source
for those creatives we then took them
and used App Engine for our pipeline
orchestration so this was where the it
kicked off the flow for the rest of the
data pipeline and what it did is that it
published jobs to cloud pub/sub which is
an asynchronous messaging queue that
then kicked off two separate work
streams the first is storing these raw
assets in cloud storage so we could do
analysis on them and the second was
running them through the vision API to
do image analysis and then storing all
of those results back into bigquery to
to run our results off of so this is the
architecture and we'll actually go
through a live demo of this so let's see
this in reality if we're looking at this
example here one of the first customers
that jellyfish went to market with for
this for this project was with Walden
University so here we have an example of
to create
creative number one in creative number
two and we want to understand which
creatives show happy faces I mean like
if you guys have been to the keynotes
like many of our leaders have said
seeing is believing so let's jump into a
live demo of how this process works and
we will will switch over to the demo now
could we please switch to the demo great
so the very first thing that we'll do is
we'll actually try out the vision API so
here this is an online website anybody
can go to cloud google.com slash vision
and upload it with your own creative so
I would recommend that you do that here
I have downloaded the creatives already
so I'm just gonna go ahead and drag and
drop verify that I am NOT a robot
in fact and we'll see the analysis here
so in a matter of seconds we were able
to get back the API calls like I
mentioned earlier we wanted to look at
faces so here we've correctly identified
that there's a face in the picture and
that joy is very likely so automatically
we're now identifying the creatives that
have happy faces versus the ones that
don't the other thing that I had
mentioned was the text analysis so here
we're able to pull out the text from
each and every single creative and
understand where they are so let's go
ahead and and reset this and try it with
our second creative so let's make sure
it works on both creatives before we
move forward with a data pipeline piece
and again we're able to see that the
faces were identified and that this face
is very neutral it's not showing any
likelihood of any emotion the other
thing that I wanted to highlight is that
this of course is a UI view so it's a
very small view of what we'll actually
be able to see when we call the API here
if we look at the JSON we can see that
these are all the information that's
being recorded as the response so we can
actually see for example the bounding
polygon and the vertices of the face
itself so it really enables you to do
whatever kinds of creative insights it
is that you want to as an organization
so now that we've proven that the vision
API piece works let's go ahead and go
into the actual data pipeline we're
gonna go into campaign manager like I
mentioned earlier which is the
ad server tool that Google that's a part
of Google marketing platform here we're
in Walden University's creatives and we
can actually see the number of creatives
that have ran and I can scroll down for
for eons on this and if I just zoom into
one of these creatives we can see some
of the issues right is that the creative
names here are really made for campaign
performance it helps us identify which
campaign this creative was a part of but
it really doesn't give us any
information about the content of the
creative itself so what we'll do is
right before I got on stage I kicked off
the data pipeline already so we'll watch
the data pipeline as it progresses and
what it's doing is it's taking this list
of creatives and putting it through that
process that I'd mentioned earlier so
I'll go ahead and go into my Google
cloud platform and here we can see that
I've kicked off the job in App Engine we
can also follow the logs in stackdriver
so here if i zoom into our logs we can
see that it's split out into two
sections the first is the is the
visionary so that's the vision API
actually doing the analysis on each
individual creative and then the second
piece here is the GCS underscore
uploader so again that is how we're
uploading these in this information back
into Google Cloud storage and then
lastly I wanted to show the data once it
lands in bigquery because while I really
enjoy getting you know seeing all the
details of how this pipeline works I'm
sure that for the business folks in the
room you really want to see what is the
value of this data once it lands so here
I've gone ahead and pulled together a
query and before I go into it I just
wanted to highlight here on the left
hand side we have the various tables
that were that came out as a result of
our data pipeline so we have the face
detection we have additional image
properties we have label detection logos
etc and then lastly we're able to join
this with performance data so now we're
able to really implement creative
analysis by seeing that performance data
side by side with our images so if I go
ahead and run this query here what we're
going to see is
the results so these are the two
creatives that we looked at earlier and
we see that in the first creative the
joy likelihood is five which is very
high and the second creative the joy
likelihood is one so here we have our
very happy face and our not happy face
we were asked to redact the number of it
clicks and impressions due to privacy
reasons however here you would be able
to see that performance information and
we'd be able to compare and contrast the
performance itself jellyfish will
actually go into the details of how they
were able to accomplish this test and
more of the value but I just wanted to
show how if we lay that foundation of
data you're able to see all of this in
one place the other thing to note here
on the right hand side is that we've
also been able to link out to the Google
Cloud Storage URL so if anybody wanted
to go through into a manual check of
these creatives it's really easy to do
that before before we leave our demo the
last thing I wanted to do was uncomment
this one line in our query so what if we
had decided instead of looking at happy
faces I want to understand if people who
are wearing graduation caps in my
creatives were able to perform better or
worse if I uncomment out this face
annotation head we're likelihood and
rerun the query I'm able to edit my
hypothesis in just a matter of seconds
and see the results here so here if you
remember in our creatives the head where
neither of them were wearing graduation
caps so we're able to see that here but
if you imagine that we're running this
off of hundreds of creatives not just
one or two then you can see exactly how
impactful being able to pull this data
pipeline together is so do you mind
please now going back to our
presentation great so thank you so much
for listening to the explanation of the
Google tools that helped to power this I
will now hand it over to James from
jellyfish to go into the business value
that this tool was able to provide
my name is James I'm a data scientist at
jellyfish
for those of you who don't know
jellyfish we are a global digital
partner as well as a global as a Google
marketing platform and Google cloud
platform certified partner we offer a
wide variety of services from creative
development and analysis to media
strategy data analysis training and much
more as part of the data team we build
solutions that help our clients
understand their big data and then take
these insights to inform their business
processes so how are we using this
solution well it meant sauer
comprehensive data strategy by informing
our data-driven creative development
strategy it helps us increase
performance as Sony mentioned creatives
account for a really significant amount
of sales and if we can just be a little
bit better at creative we can deliver
significant performance lifts and to
that end it helps us quickly and
efficiently discover what works and what
doesn't with creative development so the
first thing we wanted to do was see if
there was any meaningful information
that we could pull out from the vision
API and so we set up a series of tests
using the adjusted viewable
click-through rate as our performance
metric which is essentially clicks over
total viewable impressions we then split
our creatives into two groups having and
not having a specific feature and then
finally used a two-sample t-tests to
analyze significance so our first
hypothesis was that creatives with happy
facial expressions have historically
performed better than creatives with
faces that did not have a happy
expression there were 184 creatives with
happy faces and 16 without and we found
that creatives with happy faces perform
two times better than creatives without
happy facial expressions for our second
hypothesis we were really interested in
seeing what makes call-to-action buttons
effective in order to do that we had to
do a bit of feature engineering which is
one of the really cool things with
Google Partnership is that we're able to
build on each other's work so I used
OpenCV the computer vision library to
extract the location color contrast size
etc
of the buttons and then once we had the
location of the button we could
cross-reference that with the computer
with the vision API data to find the
text that appears inside the button and
then from there we can find out what
impacts performance positively or
negatively in terms of the text so our
second hypothesis is that creatives with
other text aside from follow your why in
the CTA button have higher historical
performance then creatives with follow
your eye in the CTA button and there
were 172 creatives with other text 16
with follow your why and we found that
creatives with other text have
historically performed two times better
than kriyas with follow your why so
we're really excited about this tool it
enables us to do much deeper creative
analysis and we started working on a
self-serve analytics dashboard which
will basically allow our clients to
track the general performance of the
different features of their creatives
and then we'll use this information to
inform our hypothesis driven analysis on
the historical data and then finally
we're going to start exploring building
a machine learning model to predict
performance based on the feature mix
thank you so much and I'm gonna give it
back to chef to talk about marketing
insights from text myself but I got a
second chance my name is chef I'm
marketing technology specialist in
Google cloud means that I'm basically a
customer engineer but I work with with
our customers when they need to bring in
their own advertising data or they have
their on premise marketing solution how
to leverage Google cloud and the
advertising side of the house in in our
products I have the privilege here to be
with Tim Tim joint join us from Colgate
Palmolive and we worked on a project
that I will tell you about where we did
something similar as James showed you
and sona but then with text and it's
hard to underestimate the value of and
the role of online reviews right so
written text these days whatever is out
there if it's on product review sites or
it's on reddit if it's on blogs people
consumers are offering up a lot of
information about what they think of
your products what they think of your
brands what went well what went wrong
and those are there's a lot of reviews
out there I looked up some numbers and I
believe for instance Yelp in 2018
had a number of hundred hundred and
seventy 1 million reviews on that site
there is no way you're gonna read those
right maybe you have hired people to
read those reviews and to see to pick up
on problems or to to think about new
features that you can add to your
product or your hotel or whatever
business you're in but that's a lot of
work right and you might miss very
important signals especially if you're
talking about thousands of SKUs that you
would have to monitor this is where
natural language processing really has
its benefit and Google Cloud has two
out-of-the-box ways to really leverage
that technology one is a pre trained
machine learning models they come in a
form of an API and that's just an API
call like we saw with Sona and James
with with the vision API there was there
was a version of it that does natural
text so just send the body of text to
the API and it will return the fields
with the different dimensions you can
also train your custom models this is
what I was talking about earlier where
you have this hybrid model where you
leverage what Google knows and what you
know especially if you're in very
specific sector like if you're law or if
it's a medical journal or there might be
jargon and certain subtleties that you
as a company really are aware of but
Google didn't optimize their the models
for right that's really where cloud out
of a male comes in so you train it to
look for those specificities that that
you know that are out there and that we
really see solutions that start with an
API graduating in Auto ml as soon as you
start to see where that value is that is
really your next step to really leverage
those subtleties so the cloud natural
language API this is what comes out so
you get a general score of the whole
body of text that comes with a magnitude
and I think we often thought we often
talk about Mac sentiment analysis but I
think magnitude or salience as we see
with entities very important features
because something can be very negative
but if it's not central to your text or
if it's not very pronounced then you
might want to rank it lower right so
it's a great way to start weighing your
results so even if you use your the API
and not an automobile model you're still
able to really pick up on some
subtleties right because you start to
see where the API might over generalize
things for entities this is where you
really leverage Google's knowledge graph
like Google has for the last decades
really try to figure out what are two
people talking about and how can we
identify phrases in Google search if you
type something in what are they actually
referring to right so there might be
five ways to talk about a car you can
now apply that knowledge graph to your
text so we'll say you talked about the
Eiffel Tower you talked about the cinema
or you talked about a conference for all
those entities you get a sentiment score
and magnitude and salience so you know
how important that element was in the
total body of the text the same four
sentences it will break out the
sentences and it does language detection
so if you have international market and
you get reviews for instance in
different languages then you can use the
API either to detect it and it's now
available in and convert from the
monitor with English Spanish Japanese
Chinese simplified in traditional French
German Italian Korean Portuguese and
Russian and this list is growing but you
see that in a multilingual environment
this is really a tool that also works
out of the box so you won't have to
translate you won't have to hire people
in different countries to do those
analytics so I this is just the first
review I ran into on Colgate toothpaste
it's this person's favorite toothpaste
it's good
carefully fighting toothpaste with added
whitener the whitening future really
works why wouldn't want to make a smile
so you see I'm not gonna be the hole
right because it's actually a lot of
text but that really goes to show that
if you want to do is that scale you need
an automated solution so similar to what
Sona and James showed we build a
pipeline where we can analyze these
reviews at scale and it starts with a
storage bucket so as you might know
Google bigquery and data analytics
really excel in situations where you
have
combinations of streaming and batching
pipelines so this is an example of how
you add batching type pipeline pipeline
to your to your architecture so let's
imagine this review comes in in in a
storage bucket there's a feature for
Google Storage is called object
notification and what it does as soon as
a file arrives or when it's updated it
sends a pub/sub notification to a topic
of your choice for people who not where
no no but pops up it pops up is a
messaging service it's basically a
select group for applications so it says
okay I've found a new file that triggers
a cloud function well that cloud
function does is it picks up the review
and it makes the API call so it just
reads the file and it sends the the
plain text to the API the API runs it
through all the Google magic and it
sends back the fields that we just walk
through the cloud function waits for the
API to to finish it adds that data it
augments the file with the data and puts
it back into cloud storage you might
wonder why you do the round-trip in
cloud storage it's because you want to
preserve like the initial state so that
if you decide to structure differently
in bigquery or you will build another
pipeline you have that data available
and with the storage options available
that it's very competitive it's not
expensive but you don't have to do that
you can also directly pipe it into
bigquery if you want it that suits your
needs better so from that arrives in
bigquery and from there it's structured
data right and it becomes available for
your for your analytics so I'm gonna
switch to the demo right now I'm gonna
show you what that looks like so I
copy/paste it well actually shown of it
thank you but you can't be pasted the
review from that we just did you saw
into the website this is a similar
online demo that you can just use on the
Google cloud website and it shows you
how the NLP API works so if we
personalize it does really nice things
with like pretty colors this is the
entities tab and it really shows the
different entities that it has
identified in this review so it knows
it's talking about cavities it knows
it's about toothpaste
it gives a type so it knows it's
consumer goods it gives you sentiments
for these different elements
it thinks whitener is that person so
that is an interesting observation
Colgate so understands that Google total
is a is an organization and this really
opens the door to also brand tracking
right so you can start to see at scale
how people are talking about your brand
not just about your product right then
you can start to see which products
might invite people to talk about your
brand right so whereas your brand
exposure the biggest rights and that
could inform investment that's not all
so we have sentiment so we get a score
for the for the whole well entire
document so that's the 12.7 with a
pretty hefty magnitude and that you see
what I what I promise per sentence what
is the sentiment that what is the
magnitude then it is so very fancy like
if you if you know languages and you
really want to dig in
Google also gives you syntax analysis so
it's it starts to designate certain
words and parts of sentences what they
mean the role they play in the sentence
and this can be really informative if
you want to start building models on top
of this right if you want to see more
linguistic analysis thank you I'm going
to switch back to the presentation all
right so I mentioned him few times now
but he's finally coming Tim thank you
for joining us so I'm a little surprised
whitening is a person he runs around in
our technology center and puts the
secret whitening and Google just
discovered him so it's trade secret out
there for the world no I happy to happen
to be here have a chance to really speak
to what we're doing with Google which is
super exciting for me as I connect
Colgate's data to decision-makers to
drive growth and value in our analytics
program key to that is a flexible set of
tools that empowers us to ride the wave
of technology that's there takes an
investment of skill take some really
good partnerships to be able to do that
but
the flywheel starts moving the
applications proliferate really quickly
for the demo you just saw once we built
that capability we found around eight
different use cases inside the company
for that that corpus of data much more
important than the data set though is
the flexible ability to go out and
gather the data that that we need for
example if we started on reviews on a
individual consumer retailer site
understood what what products people
might be asking for or sizes pack mix
that we might not be doing we might that
we might not be presenting to the world
we might then pivot from that to looking
at consumer affairs and our ability to
respond with the limited people we have
- what people are saying about our
products to translate them into
different applications so that we can
empower the teams that we already have
but data sites like that tend to be very
useful in applications like e-commerce
optimization what's great about that is
we don't end up with a balkanized set of
tools but were empowered to take a set
of data and a flexible acquisition
capability analysis capability and then
action capability chain those together
in a number of business cases and that
matters a lot as a company we have more
than three and a half billion customers
that use our products around the world
by and large the relationship those
customers are intermediated by the
distributors by the retailers that we
sell those products through so
understanding what consumers want what
they think about our products it's
really important to be able to use the
power tools that that you're shown here
and it's important to put it in the
context that the chef showed where we're
able to move around blue hexagons and
quickly rearrange and in agile II focus
our business where the value is going to
be the three points made here are first
driven by the fact that the complex
ecosystem that we're at in the world is
is discernible by the tools that you've
seen here that takes engineering and
writing code it takes an investment to
partner and build that internally that's
a major effort of ours the second part
is we need to have partnerships to prime
the pump to
what's possible in this type of context
once you do that you're passed a barrier
of entry and you can start to present to
business users whether it's in marketing
supply chain product development and
start to proliferate the use cases and
then at you enter into virtuous cycle
where demand for this type of capability
goes up and you're able to increase your
resource investment and capability in
this area and I think it's pretty clear
from everyone that using GCP for us has
been really helpful to start with a low
barrier of entry and quickly move into
doing complex things that we're able to
expand across a diverse base of users
love to talk to you afterwards about
this and thanks to chef for setting this
up for us and showing us the way awesome
so we will go ahead and do a really
quick wrap-up of what we've seen here
today
so essentially you saw two different
examples of how we can start to get
insights from unstructured data at scale
the problems that both Colgate and
jellyfish articulated are not new
problems they're things that we've been
dealing with and finding workarounds for
what's really new here is the
innovations that Google cloud has been
able to bring from a tools and
infrastructure perspective to really
help solve these problems at scale
and that is to Tim's point into James's
point the power of the partnership
between between cloud and and the
customers that we work with
[Music]
you